[Music]
our series a more perfect union is a
reminder that what unites us as
americans is
far greater than what divides us now the
economic downturn during the pandemic
has cost almost a quarter of all
hospitality workers their jobs that is
far worse
than any other industry but one jobless
bar and restaurant consultant
has landed on his feet by remaking pub
trivia
for pandemic times and as adriana diaz
show us
shows us his success is keeping people
both connected
and doing good at the same time american
rep
good morning everyone life online can
put us all in a box
welcome to your date from first dates to
court dates probable cause
but like a lot of us stephen walsh
hadn't even heard of zoom
until last march the restaurant industry
is reeling when kovit crashed his
baltimore event business
my inbox was full of cancellations i
said to my wife i was like
we're in trouble here wow you must have
been panicked when you think you have a
business and it's been going pretty well
and all of a sudden in
a few days it's gone but the ireland
native's luck turned around
when else st patrick's day when he took
an old hobby and brought it online
posting trivia on zune a thousand games
later
he's reached players in 87 countries
it's definitely the most i've earned in
my life
it's turned into a career that i don't
plan on moving back from
right regulars often play with friends
in other places
she wrote her most famous book a classic
of its genre
at age 20. but his questions that make
you think
may be the biggest draw that was
mary shelley walsh trivia it's it's hard
so hard walsh attracts jeopardy
contestants and even other trivia hosts
like laquita smith from north carolina a
trivia game is only as good as its hosts
stephen does a really great job of
keeping the audience engaged which as
a trivia host i can say it's difficult
to do in person
but let alone over zoom after so much
talk of trivia
i had to try it myself what is the
country that is home to the most people
with a name starting and ending with the
same letter
so i'm assuming it's a country that
starts and ends with a
because a lot of countries end in a oh
australia so this is where i treat you
everybody puts australia
argentina walsh crafts questions
he calls google proof one team just
high-fived and kissed
but instead of competing for cash weekly
champions pick a charity and pay it
forward
because of this so far walsh has raised
more than a hundred thousand dollars
holding whole games to benefit autism
and alzheimer's research
baltimore's ready initiative for
low-income college students and
philadelphia's youth sentencing and
reentry project
where after 31 years in prison john pace
is now helping
others with their second chance i think
they begin to trust me that
i was able to go through that experience
i made poor decisions
i was able to transition out of that and
i'm making better decisions now
how do you feel having started this as a
way to just get by
for your family and now you're able to
help others
it's been really really fantastic on
that and like people are so appreciative
and people come back not just for the
questions but for the co-hosts
correct answer do you know yeah
two-year-old jamison
number one and now his baby sister
katarina
born just three weeks ago my wife she
was like will stephen host the game from
the hospital room
checking in soon and find out turns out
the hospital wi-fi wasn't strong enough
she's given you the evil eye back but
walsh also had his hands full
with his greatest win yet for cbs this
morning
i'm adriana diaz
everybody looks like they're having a
great time yeah i mean what a great
turnaround for being in trouble in this
pandemic and then starting this and who
knew you could make a business out of
that maybe we need a trivia on the back
end of our
show why do people love trivia so much i
mean i get it i love it also
i love that it's good these made it
google proof that's a that must mean
it's really really good
i thought adriana was very brave to do a
question on camera
yes well she could please let me know
the answer please he wasn't live